le 13 octobre 2010 9 k et saez est élu
président de la république tunisienne
avec plus de 70% des voix
un jour historique pour le pays avec
l'arrivée d'un homme sans étiquette
politique et porte en lui les espoirs de
la révolution 2011
je préfère qu al sayyed
je le trouve cultiver je pense qu'il va
changer des choses pour le pays dans le
bon sens je suis contente puisqu'il est
maintenant président de la tunisie
si on voit trois millions du peuple qui
ont voté pour monsieur rayside je peux
pas être contre eux c'est la volonté du
peuple
c'est nouvelle démocratie en tunisie on
est en première année donc c'est la
majorité à accepter ce monsieur je ne
dois que me c'est à dire je dois
accepter qu'on veut c'est à dire on n'a
pas le choix je suis satisfait mais
d'entrée la tâche se complique car une
semaine avant le parti ennahdha
d'inspiration islamistes arrivent en
tête aux législatives et gagne 52 sièges
au parlement le 15 novembre et narda
plébiscite à big jim lee soixante ans au
poste de premier ministre
il échoue à former un gouvernement avec
72 voix contre 134
un échec qui permet aux chefs d'états de
lancer des consultations pour désigner
le chef du gouvernement le 20 janvier
2020 et ds fakhfakh 47 ans est nommé
mais il doit composer avec des cercles
d'influencés très implanté pour éviter
la dissolution du parlement sous la
pression des narda qui demande la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
il présente sa démission le 15 juillet
2020 dix jours plus tard hichem mais
chic 46 ans devient à son tour premier
ministre le 24 août il présente un
gouvernement de 28 ministres et
secrétaires d'état dont huit femmes
si la formation de l'équipe
gouvernementale permet d'écarter la
possibilité d'une dissolution de
l'assemblée
elle ne met pas pour autant fin aux
tensions et narda n'ayant obtenu qu'un
quart des strapontins au niveau
international le pays en pleine
ouverture notamment avec les etats-unis
un accord de coopération militaire a été
signé à tunis avec le chef du pentagone
le mois dernier objectif renforcer la
sécurité à la frontière libyenne nous
nous réjouissons d'approfondir cette
relation afin d'aider la tunisie
à protéger ses ports et ses frontières
terrestres à faire reculer le terrorisme
et à éloigner de votre pays les
tentatives néfastes des régimes
autocratiques étrangers début novembre
la tunisie organisera le dialogue
politique inter-libyen en tentant de se
poser en médiateur
un rôle qui confère à la tunisie une
place précieuse au maghreb pour une
relance du processus politique de son
allié libyen qui lui apporte également
un certain crédit au sein des nations
unies
la tunisie a pu un dialogue entre les
libyens et directement sans ingérence le
rôle de la tunisie est d'accompagner les
frères libyens afin de parvenir à des
consensus qui pourrait instaurer un état
moderne dans un futur tournage le chef
de l'état inscrit ainsi la tunisie dans
une position forte à l'international
reste désormais à faire ses preuves en
interne et à rassurer les tunisiens sur
le bien fondé de leur choix lors de son
élection